belli belli sono proprio contenta perché
oggi sono perfetti i ricci adesso vado a
dormire mi rilasso e domani mattina
saranno top per l'incontro con crush
ma che cos'ho in testa?
cos'è un nido ma non vedo neanche la
mia faccia ieri sera erano perfetti ma perché mi fate questo é scoppiata una bomba stanotte
nel letto cos'ho qua dietro oddio ma é enorme non è neanche un nodo é un rasta come cavolo
no vabbè io sono scioccata io volevo nascere coi capelli lisci ma perché
certo che questa potrebbe anche darsela una pettinata eh ha parlato ma che c'entra lei ha i
capelli lisci io ho i capelli ricci non
posso pettinarli ma in che senso non puoi
pettinarli nel senso che se li pettino
assomiglio ad Hagrid e quindi preferisco evitare
scusami adesso seriamente com'é che fai a tenerli in ordine?
non li pettino li pettino soltanto sotto la
doccia da bagnati ma veramente ok ci
siamo ragazzi la scorsa volta mi siete
piaciuti tantissimo la volta prima però
non mi siete piaciuti per niente
eravate crespi disordinati indefiniti
quindi io lo so so quali sono le vostre
potenzialità so che ce la potete fare
per favore è un'occasione importante
devo avere dei capelli perfetti
venite bene vi prego venite bene come la
scorsa volta
ma che belli sembrano quasi delle molle davvero sembrano proprio dei
fusilli ci giocherei tutto il giorno se
gli avessi anch'io mari ma dicci la verità
ogni riccio un capriccio?
io posso andare in giro così no è
illegale andare in giro così sembro uno
spaventapasseri
con tutti i soldi che spendo per
attenuare l'effetto crespo e questo me li
secca
e questo me li indurisce e questo non li
definisce abbastanza e questo li unge
basta oggi ho dei ricci tremendi metto un
cappellino e non ne voglio proprio sapere scusa
forse il colore non so il modello
sicuramente questo mi sta... basta questo mi
sta sempre bene figurati se non mi... chi
l'ha detto che chi ha i capelli ricci
non si può fare delle fantastiche
acconciature per esempio una bellissima
coda alta cosa sono ste cose
cosa sono sti bozzi io non li ho mica fatti
ma perché rifacciamo subito questa cavolo di coda
come devo fare io come devo fare devono
stae giú dovete stare giú basta
no ci mancava solo questa
i capelli incastrati nell'elastico
mari ma perché non ti tagli un
pó questi capelli perché perché nessun
taglio va bene per chi ha i capelli ricci se
se li fai scalati salgono troppo
quelli davanti e coprono gli occhi ti
danno fastidio se li fai pari sembri una
campana un triangolo tremendo se li
taglio troppo sono troppo corti se li
lascio lunghi appesantiscono e quindi va
via il volume che ti devo dire non posso fare niente con
questi capelli così devono rimanere così
cos'é sta cosa dura un lucidalabbra
un calzascarpe no vabbè non ci credo cos'è sta roba
la lampada di aladin
beh comunque i capelli ricci sono
bellissimi hai poco da lamentarti
ma tu hai idea di cosa vuol dire gestire
i capelli ricci guarda no per curiosità
vi riassumo brevemente la mia vita
allora anche se non sono sporchi i miei
capelli bisogna lavarli dopo un giorno
perché il primo giorno sono belli
definiti vaporosi il secondo giorno
fanno schifo quando li asciughi col diffusore ci metti dai 40 minuti a un'ora circa
dipende dalla lunghezza dei capelli
ovviamente ogni volta mi si crea un buco
qui dietro ma io mi chiedo ma cos'è sto buco da dove viene
tutti davanti e dietro piatti poi
un'altra cosa che proprio non sopporto
che sembri sempre in disordine non si
capisce perché poi da un lato sono in un
modo dall'altro in un altro da un lato
magari ricci belli e definiti dall'altro
flosci di quel mosso proprio indefinito
insipido che non sa di niente oggi me li
piastro e addio ai ricci non piove non
c'è umidità stanno venendo benissimo
adoro che bello vedere i miei capelli lisci ordinati
ho appena finito di piastrarli ma sono di
nuovo ricci ma non é possibile c'ho messo un'ora